Hans uh first of all congratulations a
big victory big bounceback victory
yesterday it wasn't your day what did
you do last night to recover from that
difficult loss and come back with new
energy in today's
round well um I honestly could not fall
asleep until um 5:00 a.m. o that was not
because I was outside of my hotel I was
in in the hotel
um so you were staying professional
yes well no I did not leave the hotel
usually when you say that I could not
sleep till 5:00 a.m. you would make
other assumptions um but I honestly just
could not fall asleep until 5:00 a.m. uh
this um this moment yesterday this move
F4 uh just really sort of haunted me and
uh I actually saw the idea um and that
would have just been like you know
basically winning the game so that sort
of was Haunting me um uh uh until 5:00
a.m. and then I barely didn't I didn't
even check won E4 this game I didn't
prepare at all for E4 um but uh okay he
chose an opening that um uh I knew quite
well like you probably obviously I spent
a lot of time in the opening um but I
was it's not that I didn't know the
opening it's that I was actually just
choosing the lines uh the line that I
wanted to play yes um because after the
moment he plays like Bishop C6 bc6
Bishop B3 there's a lot of different uh
ways to sort of equalize and the one I
played was just sort of uh
psychological choice just because I
thought that um after like Bishop
D3 this is all known um but it's a very
very technical position and I thought
that um perhaps he would feel uh
uncomfortable in a very slow maneuvering
game and uh eventually he he he sort of
and your alternative was in fact uh as
you mentioned to take on D4 and place
this structure which is considered to be
closer to equality but at the same time
time white is not risking that much you
wanted to keep more pieces you wanted to
keep the position in Balance right yeah
well Rook B8 the reason actually that um
Bishop C6 first like is is not is
technically not as precise as instead of
Queen B6 I can play Rook B8 um uh like
this is usually because usually you
don't need to take you can play Bishop
E3 without Bishop takes C6 right um and
then I would then there's then you do
allow the the idea of let's say Bishop
B3 but now you allow CD CD Queen B6 um
and then Queen B6 there's like uh main
move is Bishop
C6 Queen C6 and this maybe he didn't
want to allow um so this is just
allowing like I knew Rook B8 and queen
B6 are both fine but I hadn't checked it
in a while
so I just remember
this like just everything being like
pretty equal but this there's some
long-term hop just because of the
structure perhaps um but yeah he played
H4 this was the first move I didn't know
I wasn't exactly sure how to react after
H4 I thought H5 was logical I don't
think that I think that seems fine
Bishop G5 Rook E8 take de Knight E4 yes
yeah this has sort of um this was a bit
annoying but I thought it was fine how
did you assess the position at this
point because the engine was in fact
saying that you're in some sort of
danger right
now maybe I don't know it's unclear it's
hard to see like how white breaks
through um because I pring the queen to
D5 I control the
B5 maybe G4 at the right moment he has
to time it very well what was my what
was my mistake what was the mistake then
in the I wouldn't call it necessarily a
mistake again you're the engine is
saying 0.9 so he not as uh significant
right and he has toake or what is
because I know after Bishop D3 is like
the best move like what is the right
after H4 H5 May a oh okay oh A5 yeah I
just wait perhaps after B yeah so this
is this is yeah so this was critical
yeah so I calculated F6 Bishop so Bishop
F4 C5 yes um I actually saw this you
could also include well yeah and then BC
mhm but I also wasn't sure
like uh you don't include I thought like
the
issue was that let's say you take on F6
first like you
include instead of uh you take on F6
after C5 or4 yeah after F6 immediately
you take on F6 okay I thought like take
tick and then Bishop F4 oh just rookie
because my issue was C5 now uh uh C5
BC yes yes and after DC not a three so I
just have to go rookie eight yeah maybe
I I Mis evaluated yeah I should go F6
that makes sense but he missed a bit he
didn't find this move Queen to F1 and
after Rook to
back in the game you're immediately yeah
Queen B5 yeah Queen B5 I thought it's
fine I have like Queen D5 yeah I like
Queen E6 a lot it was a nice uh Queen E6
was a very nice prophylactic because
he's sort of threatening Queen H3 yes so
I thought Queen I just thought that you
know uh it was very clear that he felt
very uncomfortable in the position
because he couldn't really he can't just
like calculate he can't like Brute Force
this is sort of the style that he has
like not much uh like lacking in some
let's say like understanding uh but very
good calculator so it was clear that he
was very uncomfortable here and he tried
to like he sort of lost control like he
started going wrong here yeah and it was
at this point5 queen D6 yeah C5 take
yeah Rook C8 was a nice move and then
yeah here just uh he just sort of E6
takes yeah so he I think what he should
play is after takes I don't know Rook e
four is just a you can't explain such a
move but Rook e six um yeah Bishop C3 is
fine but I thought Rook E6 instead Rook
K C6 yeah and Bishop C3 Rook
E4 I wasn't sure how to yeah this seemed
yeah Bishop G7 and now I wasn't I was I
wasn't sure like Rook G7 no this I saw
this I saw but Rook E7 after G5 instead
of instead of Rook takes G6 instead of
Rook takes
G6 Rook Pi E7 C3 oh I guess I am fast
enough yeah this was hard to to
calculate does it look like I might be
check okay yeah so rookie eight rookie
seven yeah H Bishop f8 yeah no I saw
Bishop of f but I guess it's uh I just
couldn't really evaluate it um it looked
really weird yeah yeah okay this is prob
probably winning eventually um but he
also had only five minutes at at this
moment yeah he did and but I think just
the the momentum was shifting right he
just uh I think this type of position he
just really uh maybe doesn't have much
experience and and I think think he he
never actually I think he might have one
game in like the G6 Russell Lio so um I
think just a bit of an experience um so
Bishop C3 Rook C1 yeah there were a
couple of Final Moments yeah Bishop B5
was was yeah this was nice yeah so Rook
B so I gave a check um so the no no no
yeah this a this was this is a mistake
what because I thought Rook B2
A4 I wasn't sure how to to break two
King rookie rookie two rookie four I saw
this wait so Rook F2 King G1 Rook E2
Rook E4 Rook B2 yes and then you have to
go King F1 King
F7 and maybe I just slowly uh it's not
that clear how you break right yeah this
I wasn't sure um oh so this was a
mistake Rick R B1 was a mistake
interesting yeah it seemed what what was
the what was the so you have to play
this position basically Bishop to E3 go
a I wasn't clear Bishop just basically
play this winning winning winning
somehow yeah yeah maybe this was the
practical but he was low on time so I
thought he would uh I would assume E5
followed by King E6 things of that
nature yeah slowly slowly probably he's
in zwang eventually once I should just
bring the king to D5 and then Pawn on A6
and I probably win uh would eventually
just stuck so yeah yeah interesting and
after that you executed very nicely I
have to say it was uh final moment when
you played King E6 allow the five of
course that's just one move calculation
but uh but sorry could you just tell me
like what the mistake was like where how
could he have better defended King E2
instead of Bishop C1 after Rook to B1
and and I go check that was the only way
that he could have um continued King E2
check King B2 mhm Rook takes a takes A2
Bishop B7 Rook G2 yes interest so this
is not this is not winning Well Check
and C king7 Bishop
G but I I have two pawns I don't I guess
the king is a bit weak right yeah the
king is a bit weak I thought that it
should
be like Rook H2 it's not easy to to
assess this one right yeah I this looked
like um a oh he's just a Perpetual oh
wow that's that's insane yeah you take
the pawn but now it's just a or maybe he
has some just insane defense yeah cuz it
looked to me like a uh if you have two
pawns no I understand okay okay I guess
it's hard to evaluate yeah because this
seemed like the other one I was worried
that there might be a fortress
um but um interesting yeah after that it
was there was no chance really well
still you asked the Practical questions
you put a lot of pressure not only on
the position but on time as well well so
you did your job and you got the full
points congratulations and what are you
going to do during the rest day to uh
recharge and get ready for the next
phase of the EV well I've just found out
there's a rest day not by you but
someone told me I didn't realize there
was a rest day
[Music]
um I will uh go enjoy um St Louis's uh
finest ways of passing time you also
have to do community hours you will have
to go to some schools of course that's
what I was referring to I'm a man I'm
you know I I find it insulting that you
don't think that that's what I'm
referring to you know you should you
should maybe research my scholarship I
didn't accuse you of anything I'm a big
I'm a big you know you know Christian
Christian I'm a big charity guy you know
scholarship $10,000 giving away to young
kids you know even some you know kids
from your your Homeland Romania have
have applied that's beautiful so trust
me I'm really looking forward to the
community today and I'm looking I'd love
to find some you know strong talented
chess players who I can help support and
achieve their dreams no Absolut look I'm
just telling you because you didn't even
know it's a rest day so now I'm kind of
telling you there's a community I'm
trying to help I'm trying to help H
that's all no no no I I don't worry
don't worry don't worry I am don't worry
I'm only messing with you guys I love
commentators I love
podcasters Here We Go Again Hans thank
you very much we'll see you tomorrow
after tomorrow thank you thank you Hans
for bringing Christian down about five
notches and just keep it up I loved it
the momentum I felt the momentum
sh I don't remember seeing other players
so excited about